Freeman fighting to where he's
ultimately started out by Taric get
right taco teaming up as well now I'll
up to attacker 1b to make it a 1v1 taco
versus attacker for the first ever
pistol round on land of vertigo we'll go
to the image of giants boy do you love
to see that
well guys with dreamhack rio using it in
their official map pool over the weekend
it looks like the era of vertigo is
finally here now love it or hate it this
map looks to be here to stay and we
thought we'd mark the occasion by
compiling the best fails the best funny
moments the best falls and yeah the best
actual plays we've seen on this map from
pro players so far now guys we've
already done entire videos dedicated to
dust2 and nuke so if you're looking for
some more classic counter-strike action
don't forget to check those out too but
for now watch your step and practice
your strafe jumping because here are the
best plays we've seen so far from pro
players on vertigo
you finish out your fish obey me how
much control do they have patented right
now case righto I mean he's just the one
here
hi Frank position I don't that's right
floor on the team but he's in no man's
land doesn't have cover
that's the author angling I guess that's
good enough to headshot poor ol even
adds a third
[Music]
[Music]
I see him I see him wait I see him now
five verses - I think this third round
may becoming risky don't flash for this
corner the flash was a bit too late
that's kind of weird
your enable Jade we turned into a double
rounder five versus two with now only
three players remaining on the Tees
they're all gonna go rotating into the B
site the site the models are gonna be
perfectly placed but a little bit late
for Fitch BL to escape that kill is all
or nothing and that was it that now
should be a possible Abel Jade pushing
back in towards the site but there's so
many angles to check on this side this
is the horrible thing about vertigo is
there are a million angles to check and
not that much time to check them far
away quick
[Applause]
lady boss op op op op op op op op
bocce's this you puppies all right
you're on trade on to obedience ellipse
the a bomb site up feed tube up the wall
but the terrible I can only connect to
on just I'm gonna be a 3 on 2
babbling no chance once more spiral
opposite before the wall bangs again
just speaking about it it's way forward
thought for a second that because
nuclear was one middle coming I have the
body of the ones
Ct site isn't even think about
retrieving the rifle there's no time
left for that it's all about denying so
many kills so quickly crystal - crystal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
has been winning this duel he'll go down
but quickly Vinnie is there to trade now
they know this must be many defense left
on this side - it will be the trade to
Buster he's got to go running now the
city's aren't on the bomb just yet
they're waiting for the support I like
this case there are no could have tried
to risk it all on his own but he's just
gonna be spotting trying to set things
up for his team mate trying to let them
know where this remaining player is but
come on they're gonna be guesstimate
official I once at Kaiser Otto another
kill for him a triple in the round and
furia a running riot
what I love this game guys I love this
and I love matchmaking playing best mate
MyPlate matchmaking guy oh well guys
here we are the part of the video where
we show the content you actually came
here to see the best fails the best
falls and the best funny moments we've
seen on vertigo so far how could this
happen to me
sty get right can't hold on now tarik
and low HP it's got to play around this
smoke finds one Gold's arrow with a
second holds there alone now pushing us
closer and closer to over time the first
player to fall on land it was in fact
Volterra
look Sam do you see this
you see this j7 is fam yeah that's Kelly
got off Thank You Thomas
[Music]
right anger now proposes that map why do
we pay this much vertigo a feeling of
dizziness a swimming in the head
figuratively a state in which all things
seem to be engulfed in a whirlpool of
terror as created by Alfred Hitchcock
Sagar dystrophy so bad
[Music]
okay you can speak bro I've lived in you
man I jump it's okay what are the
terrorists on vertigo anyway they wear
suits they have cool sunglasses are they
mafia are the assassins are they bank
robbers I don't know but that's all for
this video and if you want more on
vertigo don't forget to check out our
recent don't at me where I explain why I
personally don't like the map but why it
should stay in the competitive map pool
subscribe to the channel like the video
comment below and I will see you next
time thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]